rhino now for the latest all right
gentlemen outside we're going to start
off with the radar because we continue
to see rain coming down not quite as
heavy as what we saw earlier the lighter
shades of green here indicate some light
showers but heavier showers on the
western beltway far hills
charleston all the way to russell and 2
15 there heavier rainfall though
continues out near red rock and
especially over sr 160. high elevation
snow continues at this hour good to see
that we saw some snow earlier we showed
you pictures at the five o'clock hour we
do have winter weather advisories for
the mountains above 8 000 feet
specifically that goes in effect all the
way until friday tomorrow at 4 p.m why
because we're expecting good snow above
8 000 feet and gusts up to 45 miles per
hour currently in the mid 50s outside
notice the winds have picked up through
all neighborhoods at this hour a little
chilly outside we've got a lot of clouds
and even some rainfall this hour more
rain and wind is on the way it doesn't
end tonight drier for christmas though
we'll show you the update on that and
last week of 2021 next week it's going
to be colder with maybe even a rain-snow
mix we'll pinpoint where and the timing
of all that all coming up in your most
accurate forecast brian